jetzt ist es amtlich meine damen und
herren 65 prozent der deutschen halten
olaf scholz nicht für führungsstark ja
selber schuld auch in dieser woche hat
der bundeskanzler eine klare ansage zum
thema schwere waffen für die ukraine
erfolgreich vermieden und ich finde wenn
er uns das wenig mal erklären würde aber
sein lieblingsspruch ist wohl
tatsächlich kein witz never complain
never explain kommt ihnen das bekannt
vor ja klar die ist geklaut von der
queen meine damen und herren ja
glückwunsch nachträglich
ihre majestät olaf der erste beschimpft
freche kritiker neuerdings als jungs und
mädels ein gewählter politiker muss
seine politik aber schon gelegentlich
erklären aber gut scholz tut sich halt
generell schwer mit großen
entscheidungen seine letzte war glaube
ich die hier ihre lieblingsorte
was ist meine lieblings eis sorgte
eine tüte und
schokoladeneis und 1 zitrone meisterin
schokolade mit zitrone
das wäre ja als wenn man eine regierung
zusammen schmeißt aus grünen fdp und
warte mal
scholz verbales rum bayer beim ganzen
thema schwere waffen hat übrigens leider
einen einfachen grund dafür gibt es in
der ampel keine mehrheit und das liegt
nicht zuletzt an seiner partei an der
spd dabei sind wir uns doch alle im
grundsatz einig putin darf in keinem
fall gewinnpunkt nur was folgt daraus
konkret wir geben der ukraine demnächst
wohl eine milliarde militärhilfe während
die eu putin dieselbe summe für energie
überweist und zwar jeden tag sind sie
enttäuscht von bundeskanzler scholz
ist ukrainisch und heißt soviel wie ja
was denn sonst
übrigens sagt herr scholz andere nato
partner dürften gerne panzer liefern und
damit ins kriegsrisiko gehen was wir
dann später irgendwie kompensieren das
ist kein pazifismus das ist eine
unverschämtheit genau wie das mit der
dubiosen waffen liste aus der sich die
ukraine angeblich was aussuchen darf wir
sind gerade dabei eine industrie liste
abzuarbeiten die wir mit dem
verteidigungsministerium in der ukraine
rückgekoppelt haben und wo jetzt geguckt
was davon unter den ausgesuchten
lieferungen auch konkret gewünscht wird
mein gott einsatz wie ein verkehrsunfall
wirklich
zu dieser liste sagt der ukrainische
botschafter übrigens stünde nichts drauf
was die ukraine wirklich braucht
beziehungsweise es steht nicht mehr
drauf denn das kanzleramt hat die liste
schon vor wochen bekommen und dann alles
entfernt was deutschland nicht liefern
möchte hier kommt es mir ist eine extrem
aufwendige bastelarbeit
dass der kanzler für sowas zeit hat toll
meinen urlaub wenn du keine schweren
waffen liefern willst wofür es ja
durchaus argumente gibt dann sag es doch
fällt ihnen das eigentlich auch auf der
scholz wird immer mehr zur merkel ist
mein eindruck wirklich oder doch
der natürlich verstörendes bild oder ja
wirklich die parallelen sind
offensichtlich seine ampel reagiert nur
stadt marl voranzugehen und konflikte
werden mit geld zugeschüttet merkels
teil da klingen selbst die
koalitionspartner in der ampel ja
inzwischen nicht mehr so richtig
begeistert aber einer hat den hut auf
und der bundeskanzler ich schätze ihn er
macht einen macht seine aufgabe er
macht seine aufgabe
wenn dir das einer ins praktikumszeugnis
schreibt musste mich nirgendwo mehr
bewerben marie agnes strack zimmermann
eine der schärfsten kritikerinnen des
zauber kanzlers getoppt wohl nur noch
von toni hofreiter der sagt scholz
abwarten der politik könne letztlich zum
dritten weltkrieg führen i
darunter macht das nicht
von ihm stammt auch der wenig subtile
satz das problem sitzt im kanzleramt es
ist wirklich verblüffend 18 drauf toni
hofreiter ist grüner redet in talkshows
aber wirklich nur noch über waffen über
nichts anderes mehr was haben sie denn
eigentlich ins futter getan
toni hofreiter
jahrelang war der lustige langhaarige
brummbär der deutschen politik
sein fachgebiet waren grüne bohnen
dunkle bohnen dicke bohnen und wenn er
ganz crazy golf auch mal radieschen bis
zu dem tag als ihn dieser hässliche
pullover das ministeramt gekostet hat
das war eine bewegung zu viel aus doctor
anton hofreiter wurde toni hofreiter
denn plötzlich alles überwachen weiß pt
91 das sind kaum fährt gesteigerte t-72
ausgemusterte marder schützenpanzer die
82 es hat zwölf
projekte
ein müsli die faxen dicke
ja eine metamorphose
also wir zählen zusammen mindestens zwei
prominente ampelanlagen den offenen
aufstand gegen den bundeskanzler und die
spd schmoldt nur noch von morgens bis
abends weil sie willy brandts ostpolitik
diskreditiert sieht meine keiner hat was
gegen friedensbemühungen aber nord
stream 2 hat nun mal putin gestärkt und
ganz wichtig die ukraine aktiv
geschwächt die alte röhre ein
lieblingsprojekt der spd vor allem von
manuela schwesig naja um sie zu retten
also um die röhre zu retten wurde eine
angebliche umweltstiftung gegründet die
in wirklichkeit us-sanktionen umgehen
sollte so jetzt stellt sie auch noch
raus bei der ausgestaltung dieser
stiftung hat man sich wohl
formulierungen direkt vom russischen
staatskonzern diktieren lassen ja ein
ungeheuerlicher verdacht hat der
schwesig damals jemand aus moskau die
texte geschrieben gibt es da ja
irgendwelche indizien sollen wir mit
saudi arabien geschäfte eingehen
oder sollen wir das machen worum es den
usa in wahrheit wirklich geht was wir
ihr fracking gas abkaufen allein darum
geht es diese handelnden personen in den
usa und das müssen wir zurückweisen er
war noch unauffällig gelöst oder nicht
sie will in keinem fall zurücktreten hat
schwesig gestern nochmal gesagt eine
andere eine kollegin von ihr hat genau
das schon hinter sich mit anne spiegel
verliert die ampel ihre erste ministerin
das ging schnell rücktritt wegen
frankreichurlaub kurz nach der
zahlenflut und wegen hier wie heißt das
noch wenn man nicht die wahrheit sagt
vergesslichkeit richtig
diana hatte zunächst behauptet sie hätte
im urlaub per sumann kabinettssitzung
teilgenommen hat sie aber gar nicht wie
erklärt man die lüge ich hatte die info
dass
in meinem kalender während meines
urlaubs
die kabinettssitzung stehen
das ist ja wohl mit abstand die beste
ausrede seit der hund hat meine
hausaufgaben gefressen
ich weiß doch ob ich gearbeitet oder mir
ampullen noch ein passiv eingeläutet
haben dafür brauche ich doch nicht
meinen kalender aber kommt nicht
nachtreten sie ist wenigstens zurück
getreten worden oder selbst keine ahnung
in würde zurücktreten meine damen und
herren ist jedenfalls heutzutage eine
kunst katja gartz gibt in berlin
seminare zum thema richtig nicht
zurücktreten ihre kunden sind politiker
die aus verschiedenen gründen eigentlich
zurücktreten müssten aber irgendwie
können book haben
gerade falsch
totales mühsam 1 hat wird sofort auf das
zu denken ganz simple regel wenn wir das
bedürfnis habt für irgendwas
verantwortung zu übernehmen stellt euch
eine frage was würde an die feuer machen
ungeschlagener deutscher meister im
spiel
der gerade
eine halbe milliarde durchs klo gespült
und dann sitzt der warrants mit solchen
eier kein fehler und sich auch nichts
vorzuwerfen
ist der goldstandard leute und frau
spiegel tritt zurück wegen vier wochen
frankreich beim an die wenn man über
jeden tag urlaub vor gewesen
von anne spiegel könnt ihr echt nur
lernen wie man es nicht macht ja die
märkte nicht mal wenn sie live auf
sendung ist wird oft weil wir sie als
original nur einer hier meine von mir
verfasste dissertation ist kein plagiat
ich werfe
diese nummer ist das laut gewesen ist
gerade nein ok schulden
jetzt kommen wir mal zum praktischen
teil wir simulieren jetzt eine pk die
trümmer von den grünen
ja und zwar folgendes in meinem
lebenslauf steht ich hab meinen master
an der cambridge university gemacht
allerdings war es tatsächlich an der
fernuni hagen
dafür möchte ich
mal zum punkt ich kann ihnen auch
erklären warum das so passiert ist also
mein mann hat sich damals von mir
getrennt und das bringt gar nichts ich
wieder hier erfährst du typ von der cdu
versucht diesmal
ich habe mit einem einzigen masken deal
millionen verdient und sitze trotzdem
noch im bundestag habt ihr ein problem
mit ich nicht so wird's gemacht
danke perfekt noch besser geht gar nicht
so jetzt hab ich noch einen stargast für
euch sein vortrag heißt du mir ist gar
nichts mehr peinlich und mein vertrag
läuft ewig herzlich willkommen eure
eminenz kardinal rainer maria rilke
[Applaus]
gemeinsamen und herren der krieg in der
ukraine war natürlich auch das
beherrschende thema bei den
ostermärschen am wochenende die waren
diesmal sehr gut besucht aber auch
kontroverse als sonst im aufruf für die
friedensdemo in berlin stand zum
beispiel kein einziges wort über
russland weil sich die friedensbewegung
darüber zerstritten hat man könnte sogar
sagen die friedensbewegung ist im krieg
mit sich selbst ja ja es ist sogar
aktivistinnen der ersten stunde lang
diesmal irgendwie unfriedlich waffen
nieder und 48 jahre lang und es ändert
sich nix und ich wäre immer wütender
spielen jetzt 80 könnte platzen ich gehe
durch das kommende apple wohl wieder
hoch freunde
hessische friedens omis außer kontrolle
man kann ihren frust sehr gut
nachvollziehen also ich selbst bin
großer friedens fan und privat noch nie
irgendwo einmarschiert aber das recht
auf selbstverteidigung hat die ukraine
schon selbstverständlich und einige
ratschläge aus der friedensbewegung an
die überfallenen ukraine klingen gelinde
gesagt seltsam wenn er zum beispiel
einer in seinem idyllischen vorgarten
sitzt und fordert dass das man sich
nicht wert wenn die russen einmarsch in
die städte dass man zivilen widerstand
organisiert dass man massen
demonstrationen und protestkundgebungen
macht
die ukraine sollen sich gefälligst
widerstandslos erobern lassen und dann
können sie später bei putin immer noch
eine demo anmelden oder so hat wohl
einer zu lange in der sonne gesessen was
andere ostermarschierer haben sogar
putins narrativ verbreitet und wieder
mal die nato als den großen bösewicht
auf ihr transparent gemacht ja
umgekehrt gilt natürlich gegen
waffenlieferungen seien macht einen
nicht automatisch zum putin fan ist ja
klar also außer jetzt bei pro putin dem
muss natürlich
gibt es ja auch ne meine spätestens da
spätestens da erkennst du was die ganze
kreml propaganda so anrichtet im
menschlichen gehirn und jetzt plötzlich
es wird verboten sprechen ihm einkaufen
geld wo russisch und das ist finde ich
traurig und schade
wer verbietet das denn
dass menschen zu menschen werden
ungefähr vier bittet offiziell keiner
gut verbot ist komplett ausgedacht aber
trotzdem schlimme sache
[Musik]
eine abmahnung an mich selber wegen
kultureller aneignung das geht da es
gibt viel ärger so und nur mal nebenbei
solchen demos müssen wir irgendwie
aushalten und zwar um uns zu
unterscheiden von putins russland
deswegen ist es meiner meinung nach auch
falsch dass jetzt in mehreren
bundesländern
ermittlungsverfahren laufen gegen das
öffentliche zeigen dass buchstaben z als
symbol des krieges was zum beispiel
macht jetzt zur nur ein beispiel
sitzt wahrscheinlich bald in u-haft
zusammen mit gysi top 16
nein
was ich damit sagen wir natürlich es ist
ein ekliges symbol das z gar keine frage
aber letztlich muss man in einer
demokratie wie unserer sogar die
meinungsfreiheit von idioten verteidigen
von leuten die seit jahren nur putins
propaganda konsumieren lügen in
dauerschleife
jetzt haben russische medien zum
beispiel mal veröffentlicht wie arm der
putin in wirklichkeit ist demnach liegt
der mann in einer 77 quadratmeter
wohnung
und besitzt ein pkw-anhänger
wussten sie dass er am existenzminimum
lebt das ist ja fast schon fall für rtl2
vladimir p hat sein leben lang
gearbeitet und andere länder überfallen
und doch bleibt dem nichts außer diesem
auto anhänger und dieser armseligen 300
zimmer villa mitten in einem traurigen
brennpunkt viertel am aussterben dieser
palast an der schwarzmeerküste bietet
eine unterirdische eishockey halle ein
theater eine bühne für striptease
auftritte und einen privatstrand nur ein
privatstrand und eine winzige schuppe
für die man von echten oligarchen
ausgelacht wird so viel armut und
trotzdem wird wladimir noch von
deutschen asiens angeschnorrt oft
schießt sich der mittellose frührentner
zum abendbrot eine streunende katze
traurig jetzt bei rtl 2 armes russland
diktaturen ganz unten
und falls sie liebe zuschauer zuhause
ich jetzt überhaupt noch sehen können
durch ihren trend schleier experten
streiten ob der hartz4 wladimir 40 70
oder doch 200 milliarden dollar besitzt
1,2 milliarden davon hat er allein im
letzten jahr in auslands propaganda
investiert und das geld ist wirklich top
angelegt ich sag nur frankreich marine
le pen kann übermorgen könnte übermorgen
französische präsident in werden und die
ist ja wie sagt man dass quasi ein
geschöpf von putin er hat sie erschaffen
es ist ja so
finanziell unterstützt von russischen
banken putin will die eu kaputt kriegen
und mit marine le pen könnte es durchaus
klappen was kommt da auf uns zu
gernot hassknecht erklärten nur 161
sekunden was man über marine le pen
wissen muss so wenn's blöd läuft haben
wir ab sonntag aber schön die mörder am
dampfen putins blonde filiale könnte die
eu von innen sprengen noch 2014 hat ihre
partei einen millionenkredit von
russischen bank gekriegt trotzdem könnte
sie gewinnen warum nur ein wort katzen
le pens ganzer internetauftritt basiert
auf muschis guck dir das an michael haft
man sieht doch wie das tier leidet ich
fahre den hashtag mit
70 waren locker mütterlich da vergisst
man fast dass sie um mehrwert steuern
senken zu können migranten die
sozialleistungen kürzen will und was sie
früher so alles über putin gesagt hat 90
ich stelle fest die regierung putin muss
in russland sehr populär sein denn sie
wird ja ständig wiedergewählt
putin konkurrenten werden wahlweise
erschossen oder vergiftet aber gewonnen
ist gewonnen alte flyer mit diesem foto
lässt marin gerade einstampfen und wenn
jemand bei wahlkampfauftritten tut ihn
anspricht passiert folgendes die person
wird sagen wir mal sanft aber bestimmt
nach hause geschleift wieso schickt sie
sich eigentlich für das bild hier es
gibt unzählige fotos von deutschen
politikern mit putin fängt mal ein putin
bild wo gerd schröder nicht drauf ist
selbst die berühmte szene
wenn man da genauer hinguckt
siehst du
die pänz bürgerliche tarnung
funktioniert leider exzellent will sagen
hoffentlich fangen die säcke von der afd
nicht auch noch an harmlos klingenden
quatsch zuprosten das brot verhält
ich sag ja zu werden
das wort heißt ja
aber noch viel wichtiger was wird denn
im worst case aus der wunderbaren
deutsch französischen freundschaft
in anbetracht dieser unterschiede werden
wir die zusammenarbeit mit berlin
beenden was dann wohl cottier ich ab
sonntag nicht nur russische sondern auch
französische produkte kein bordeaux mehr
kein ort vor keine gänseleber
das geht ja gar nicht ich würde
verhungern
ist
na ja genau ja ja die zuschauer
mittlerweile fast alle versteckten
symbol ihr bei uns im neuen studio
gefunden illuminati freimaurer
staatsführung ist alles dabei dann
wollen wir denn die eigentlichen
strippenzieher bekanntgeben
er ist nicht so viele abonnenten auf
youtube
also ich würde mich ran halten